[Music]
my sister's for a minute
[Music]
ah now we will we have all your eggs
yeah and there's nothing you could do
about it red point conjoint point you're
gonna be crying in a second right take
your bets and PEG dollar
[Music]
[Music]
hey it's me
red you know the guy everybody hated who
kind of saved the whole island anyway
war with Leonard in the pigs what are
you gonna do I'm a foodie still going on
those what and Bob and Chuck are doing
whatever they do I eat dirt and me well
I still have some anger issues but I'm
finding healthier ways to deal with it
Fred
I know we've had our differences but
we've discovered that there's a third
island maybe one good reason why I
should believe you now show you the
proof will team
[Music]
really
we pet this is a hundred times my sister
silver I just don't think you're gonna
be compatible with the team oh wow it is
such a pleasure to meet not you but you
I like her we gotta get to the island is
what my assistant was going to say
[Music]
this is the amazing team I've been
working around the clock
well that's disappointing what will
break in and deactivate the weapon we
look amazing we gotta get that key card
hello fellow eagle God how he's doing a
voice yeah I'm just gonna
[Music]
[Music]